right now I'm going to show you the room
that my two children I share inside my
parents told me their total ten people
is in here I'm also living out of my
trunk because there's not much space in
my room
come on in really tight in here shoes
clothes I just try to utilize all the
space that I can I have things under the
bed right here I made this cool library
for my boys they really like when I read
to them here's my study area I've shoes
under the desks I had nowhere else to
put them
it's really hard to study right here
when my boys are just right behind me on
the bed like I said it's very crowded in
here I'm just trying to do the best that
I can to make it work you know I have to
do what I have to do so that was a tour
of the room she shares with her two boys
right now she lives in a house with ten
other people before the break Kevin and
I do monji sized her Christmas with toys
and a scholarship to finish nursing
school well we said um Morgan and
Jumanji sighs her Christmas ryankevin we
did say that have we done that I don't
think I don't think we've completely
Jumanji sized Jumanji is a big movie yes
that's a really big movie exactly I feel
like we're definitely under the bar at
this yeah under the bar I think we can
go there's another level okay that can
be reached reach another level all right
let's take this
Jumanji sighs Christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our friends at Xfinity also heard
ondrea's story and wanted to help
Xfinity is providing her and her boys
with a newly remodeled and newly
furnished two-bedroom apartment all for
them all free for one whole year
Xfinity knows that the Internet has the
incredible power to keep us all
connected because of this Xfinity is
also making sure entre and her kids stay
connected with free internet service for
a year that is so helpful with studying
I know that and we have Miguel Martinez
VA from our Philly affiliate NBC 10
standing by for a grand tour of ondrea's
new place look at that monitor I'm so
excited to show you your new home I'm
gonna give you a little tour here Andre
it's beautiful in here let's take a look
around so when you walk in the front
door the first place you're gonna see is
your bedroom the boys they get their own
bedroom you don't they get bunk beds
right there you can see kind of train
your dragon' beam in here it's beautiful
and it comes complete right next to your
room which own space I mean we were
talking about space earlier look you get
your own beautiful bed and take a look
at that desk I know you're finishing up
nursing school that is a prime study
location just for you on Draya and then
right here this is the family space so
you get the kitchen brand new stainless
steel appliances brand new Greta
countertops and everything right next to
the living room so you get that new TV
from our friends over at Xfinity and
take a look behind me here because it's
the holiday season a beautiful decorated
Christmas tree and presents for the
whole family to this beautiful space it
is right next to where you're currently
living so just a few blocks away the
kids they could stay in their own school
it's so close to where you are now but
this it's your own so I don't know
Andreea how do you feel oh my god I'm
just blessed and grateful I did not
expect this thank you from the bottom of
my heart
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this